I'm my wife and I are big American Idol
fans would go way back so I'm really
feeling a little star-struck it's
clearly squared squared happening right
now there's a lot of personality sitting
here I like yet we are both actually
very similar you are sexist I'm Caroline
bubbly yeah we both started on Idol yes
and I have no idea until literally last
night that one of your audition songs
was since you've been gone
yes oh my gosh I didn't know that yes um
well oh well thank you
no I you know there's so many different
rounds before you even get to even get
to Paul Iranian Simon which we have the
original three oh my god gosh nobody
does that
I actually audition with the sweetest
thing yes Newton yeah went through to
the next round and then saying that one
again I thought maybe this will be good
keep doing this one and I think it was
Paula had asked me to sing something
could you sing something pop and I went
I just started singing your song no way
and I was terrified because you Pig I
mean I just I would not be my go to
first person that came to mine and then
20 seconds of something else and so I
think broken wing by Martina oh good
song do the same thing charm for me it
got me through to the next round
oh that's awesome they had all of us do
that though everybody thinks it's like
one song I just sing like three
different one again yeah I was like am I
still proving that I can sing on key
here like what's happening this is
amazing backstage dish we are spilling
the tea so we I heard we also have
something in common you looked right my
husband I eloped
that's right had a whole plan oh my gosh
us too yeah and then I don't know we are
we had this whole big wedding planned in
Nashville and the only thing we had
failed to do was send invitations out so
I'm looking at the Gateway and what so
this
on purpose you forgot to invite people
no I'm getting to it so we we we have
this list and I'm going he'll I mean
like half of these people I don't even
know the rest
you know because you like this person
and that person and then you gotta it's
just gotta be this big exactly why can't
you and it felt like a CMA afterparty
yeah I'm just like this big production
and it's supposed to be about your mom
now I live baby let's just a runaway
yeah you guys who thought you never
asked we don't tell anybody and just ran
off that's so awesome he was sweet about
it perfect for us everybody has to do
what's right for them I will say you had
a very rare honeymoon location
we're in Baghdad that's right well
that's the place to go no i-i've been
working with the USO for many years and
I was booked to go on one early January
so we said I do and then hopped on a
plane and flew over seas to rockin yeah
it's been our honeymoon there at each
spot that we would stay at had a
honeymoon suite for us it was the
funniest thing we had a ball that we
wouldn't crash it's so sweet that's cool
that you fallen through it is very
important they sacrifice a lot say what
you mean mean what you say and honor
your word get it
[Applause]
what about your wedding - Joel oh poor
did you have a big wedding we had a
secret wedding in our backyard with 25
people and mostly people that were on
your list so there's some country music
no we just we had the same thing where
we just said you know what let's not do
the big to-do let's just keep it very
small and in fact it was a surprise
wedding it was the night before the
Emmys and Megan was nominated so we had
her families come and we just had him
over and we said oh by the way if you
step into the backyard this is our
wedding we met doing a play in Los
Angeles I she was a couple years into
Will and Grace and I was living in
somebody's basement and she was like I'm
sick of classy individuals we find a
carpenter Kelly tell us about your movie
its mistletoe secret right hallmark yeah
I play a small-town girl from North
Carolina so it wasn't far of a stretch
yeah and I'm trying to save my little
town and bring small businesses help
them come back to life and and bring
tourists there there's a love interest
that comes into place of course nothing
and so much drama because its hallmark
you know ya know it's a sweet little
love story and I get - yeah they're
feel-good movies right they all have
happy endings I love life I know right
that's why I'm like Oh a Christmas
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going